friends of mine got blackout drunk and  caused over five thousand dollars worth  of damage to the dorms my freshman year  of college it was a saturday night and  everything started off normal the guys  were in the dorms getting drunk normal  weekend then  they ripped shots of tequila the next  day the dorms were absolutely destroyed  couches were torn apart the exit signs  all ripped down the ceiling tiles  broken when the cops came it amassed  over five thousand dollars worth of  damage and unfortunately there was video  of the guys doing everything they didn't  even remember what happened and they  woke up to a five thousand dollar bill  and police officers at their dorm that  my friends is why you don't drink  tequila